si vous gagnez moins de 4000 euros qui
vous gagner 4000 euros avec mon système
vous payez moins les autres paieront
beaucoup plus et je ferai la peau à
universel alors il faut vous dire
l'impôt universel ça veut dire que où
que vous soyez dans le monde
vous payez votre part d'impôts dans le
pays où vous êtes un et puis au regard
de la différence combien vous devez si
vous êtes si vous étiez en france
aujourd'hui tous les députés européens
par un système que j'ai inventé tous les
députés européens déclarent et payent
leurs impôts au fisc européen puisque
c'est le seul qui existe
et puis il déclare en france je les fais
puis ans était née papelard partout mais
enfin bon on fait la comparaison est ce
qu'on millions devraient si on était
imposé en france et on donne en retirant
ce qu'on a déjà donné de l'argent d'une
longue tout le monde paye
il y aura l'impôt universel figure
debout je raconte ça à tf1 à premier
soir et le lendemain arrive sarkozy et
qu'est ce qui dit la même chose alors là
la journaliste lydia vous dites comme
mélenchon était très embêté parce que
dire comme mélenchon s'est pratiquement
se vouer les amis quand l'eau france
pourquoi pas le revenu n'est pas
américain alors attends là je parle de
l'info universal et les américains alors
au volant rosen hicher rire tout le
monde en parle en sortir il a nous les
américains ils s'embêtent pas ils ont
demandé à toutes les banques du monde
mais de vérifier l'american itude de
l'oréal à bord en france et qui m'ont
dit sont là raconte dis pas que ces
nouveaux lieux j'en il ya des insoumis
partout même dans la chronique mais dans
ce sens vous avez conscience jean-luc
unit ou est-ce que elle l'a dit elle à
elle a évoqué le sujet laurent ça y est
tous les plus riches font partir moi
j'ai joué c'est ce qui est des mêmes
raconte tout temps avant moi je vous le
dis moi et j'ai avec plein de gens qui
me disaient je le dis aussi je disais
jean luc mélenchon va être au 2e tour en
je le sens y monte qui monte il monte il
ya plein de gens qui ment pas il a une
vraie vraie cote
et il ya plein de gens très riches qui
me disait ah bah moi s'il ya c'est jean
luc mélenchon de toutes les façons c'est
sûr et certain je fais mes valises le
lendemain comment on va faire quand vous
allez les retenir alors d'abord c'est
pas nouveau
en 81 il se rattrape et tellement ils
étaient bêtes ils emmenaient leur langue
dans leur bagnole il faisait chaud plat
frontière suisse était ridicule
connaissons déjà les deux mondes
alors aidons quoi vous et de lingots
d'or non non mais j'en ai pas prendre
chercher à la maison j'en ai mais vous
devriez parce que
ça nous va mal tourner y'a plus première
discussion marc voilà mais comment je
m'y prends d'abord je réforme le système
fiscal pour qui et quatorze tranches à
dire que tous ceux qui sont à 4000 euros
paye moi parce que pour l'instant c'est
ceux qui sont au milieu qui paye pour
tout le monde et c'est pas vrai deuxième
jetables et l'argent des français quand
même à l'établi leur peau universel et
pourquoi pas le revenu universel à temps
mais de tendance par l'impôt c'est autre
chose c'est autre chose revenu et je
suis sur l'impôt suis d'accord donc
j'établis l'impôt universelle qui prend
la forme que je viens de vous dire alors
après ils peuvent aller sur mars
parce que de toute façon on dira ah mais
vous vous êtes français alors vous payez
donc fait parce que la france vous a
comme a dit dans ton on n'amène pas à
pas lents mais elle a su faire je vous
dis la vérité là dessus sans lui vous
n'y arriverez pas parce que les mecs il
faut naître il ya des familles qui ont
des sous en france et qui payent leurs
impôts en france mais moi j'en connais
au moins parce qu'il se trouve que je le
connaissais
j'avais d'innombrables sujet
d'engueulades avec lui et de désaccord
c'était serge dassault et serge dassault
me dit moi je paye mes impôts en france
c'est un milliardaire mesuré voilà donc
faut pas croire non plus que parce que
on est riche on est forcément un tordu
et en s'allongeant lieu qui veut pas
cotisé pour les autres rien on va
remettre une petite pièce sur un truc et
on va aborder un sujet un petit peu
épineux ya plein de gens qui lisent
aussi et je le dis souvent ici avec
raquel vos parlons de vous vous faites
aussi vous instaurez une haine anti
riches nasa non il ya plein de gens qui
regardent
non mais c'est pas ça suffit quoi la
haine en tyrie je dis que ce sont le
racisme anti riches dans ceux qui ont le
plus doivent donner le plus ceux qui ont
le moins des êtres des chasseurs est
banale et c'est pas de la haine anti
ride bien sûr que non et c'est d'abord
parce qu'ils se sont sauvés pour la
plupart d'entre eux vient de l'apprendre
les 50 premières fortunes de france 37
se sont cachés au luxembourg pour pas
payer
il reviendra le luxembourg je sors nu
pays le plus avant de poser de l'osce et
de jean luc mélenchon pardon on est le
pays le plus d imposer doit céder mais
la raison c'est vrai que le que je sais
pas si c'est vrai mais ce sujet
ce qui gêne avions fiscales donc
l'argent il fallait le trouver là
d'abord dombasle attend 80 à 100
milliards d'accord donc il faut
embaucher des gens au fisc saison
réduite 3000 les postes deuxièmement il
y avait un impôt sur la fortune quand
même c'était pas la mort cet impôt sur
la fortune
au delà de 1200000 de capital pas votre
logement parce que quand de dole votre
logement
il a abattu de 30 % 1 sa valeur donc
c'était vraiment du capital ça allait
tuer de payer 800 euros par an sur leur
capital non alors et puis il faut
arrêter attendez moi je veux dire une
chose que quelqu'un je suis pour un
système d'économie mixte j'ai jamais dit
jade et nationaliser tout et prendre des
sous de tout le monde c'est pas mon
sujet je suis pour que y ait un secteur
public puissant ordonnée qui indique
dans quelle direction on va ça s'appelle
la planification écologique on sait dans
quel sens on bat à partir de là il ya
les moyens de l'état et puis a les
moyens privés et je dis aux gens qui ont
des sous mettez-vous sous dans en france
dans de la boîte française donc du
travail français et s'en va on
descendait d'accord mais je voulais
encore parler de haine anti riches sans
monture et ben moi je n'ai pas du tout
donné ce soir quand on aborde tous les
sujets mais oui tous les to les voilà
tout tout tout n'est pas à jeter sur les
pauvres alors du coup je suis un an
thierry a détourné au nom et prénom mais
sa mairie s'il ya des pauvres c'est
parce qu'il ya des très riches un jour
là les médias comparent rapport que je
comptais pas poursuivi roy mais pas les
opposer mais pardon c'est tout qui les
laisse mourir enfin mais enfin l'apport
est recomposé presevo à paris mais vous
avez bien réduit pour les plus à l'est
pas honte de le faire
semenya au chaud et bien moi pareil vous
n'avez aucune calorie man 10 millions de
pauvres dans ce pays parce qu'un acquis
sont devenus horriblement riche dense a
pas de rapport non ya les riches d'un
côté les pauvres de l'autre ils se
connaissent pas un petit bijou pas de
rapport mais il assure qu'il ya un
rapport à son très beau minutes secondes
pendant la crise du coc vite se sont
gorgés d'argent vous vous êtes dans
l'âme ou jusque là 2 ils sont
tranquilles ils s'en foutent de vous ils
vivent ailleurs ils vivent dans leur
truc
il y avait dans leurs moyens mis en uvre
ça c'est la vie
jay chou plébiscité serge dassault y en
a plein qui sont là qui payent leur vin
possible attribution des emplois j'ai
dit quelque chose contre la rva
justement il faut il faut lire je suis
en train de vous dire mais vous pointez
du doigt ceux qui sont collés les chefs
d'entreprise et enfin nos rôles en
grande majorité des quêtes mais le vrai
il crée donc l'aborder là et comment
vous allez faire un tour c'est cher et
ne vont pas passer cette année on va
vous sinon demain la circulation du
capital s'est pas c'est pas le capital
qui créent la richesse et le travail
humain tout le monde sait maintenant
après ben il faut qu'ils aiment capitale
pour déclencher comment vous allez faire
jean luc si oui toutes les personnes qui
ont extrêmement bien réussi en france ce
parc est plongé mais ils partiront plus
grande écoute le nombre de chômeurs qui
va y avoir et je ne partirons pas un
grand nombre d'entre eux sont des trios
rit jean luc hamel ans il avait réglé à
400 mhz et ceux qui gagnent plus de
400000 euros par mois si vous le redis 4
avril pas non mais là il ya le 90% au
dessus de 400 mille euros par an si la
peau se renvoyant vers des six mois
expliqué c'est à dire mais moi je sais
que vous croyez quoi les très riches
400000 euros par an tous ceux qui vous
allez dire au dessus de 400 mille euros
par an je prends 90% nom est vraiment
déjà vous raconter une salade donc vous
le dire car c'est elle je viens de vous
dire c'est la dernière étrange alors
d'abord vous pour aider pas 90 % des 400
livres d'après les 400 m mais ça s'est
produit il connut ses prix vérifier s'il
y avait 75 ans
conneries on a ramené sa puis ça n'en
finit plus quand j'ai commencé les
argumentaires en dida on va réduire la
base sur les entreprises à augmenter les
impôts ddea où vous trouvez en mai
rappelle jean magique un lézard yeux
on a rallié on n'a pas dit on a juste
dit que j'avais bien compris gens sont
au dessus de 400 mille euros pour des
90% par parents je vous le dis tout le
monde va se marie à bas tous les plus
riches aux barrages voitures ne laissez
pas les enfants fait merci bien commencé
non mais attendez je trouve les
entrepreneurs ils font part dont moi moi
je suis moi même allé en tant qu'avocat
trophées sont gainés plus de 400000
euros par an où je vais vous durera pas
mais mes avocats crème la misère lille 2
o h2o cette boîte qui produit cette
émission la clientèle entre guillemets
c'est le public à la maison on n'a pas
délocalisé l'émission pour faire ballons
sont pas dans quel pays bon alors des
médailles à rien en vérité en france
beaucoup d'activités économiques qui ne
fonctionne qu'avec jeu les français
attendent et qui ne feront que jamais
délocaliser cyril hamelin et je vous
dirai télé je jouais pas je voudrais
arrêter mcewan avec la 1ère fois que je
vous le dis aujourd'hui je pense que je
fais partie et je le dis je suis pas le
mien mais il est très riche c'est vrai
mais je pense essayer de fierté pour moi
sympa non c'est une fierté pour moi de
payer beaucoup d'impôts je vous le dis
parce que c'est la france qui a fait un
mine de rien mon succès aujourd'hui
alors je dis pas que je suis je suis
content de payer blé vous les emmenez
moi je vais rester oui mais moi non mais
moi je vais rester ya aucun souci
si vous êtes là en plus maintenant on
est potes on arrêtera l'elysée mais il
fallait le dire moi je vous le dis il y
en a plein qui vont se marrer c'est ça
qui me fait de la peine qui vont se
barrer déjà sert à rien qu'ils s'en
aillent les rattrape avec un pot
universel et deuxièmement je vais te
dire mais reçu hanouna on ne peut pas
vivre sous la menace des gens qui n'ont
pas de morale comme si ça leur fait rien
que le pays soit dans la mouise et qui
s'en vont avec leur argent est bien au
revoir simone les brouilles et s'en veut
on n'a pas besoin d'eux des gens
intelligents en france y en a des
milliers
des ingénieurs des chercheurs des
architectes ils sont prêts à se dévouer
pour le pays
ils sont prêts alors ça suffit le
chantage à metz en lui une poignée de
gens qui nous menace riches le
cambrioleur passent pas leurs quatre
caviars il ya plein de riches qui aime
la france et qui est alors libéré il
faut pas chercher à me faire dire des
choses que j'ai pas dit mais je n'ai pas
dit je vous ai cités d'assaut après tout
je ne suis pas obligé de de citer une
famille mais ça voilà des industriels
j'ai des copains qui sont syndicaliste
chez dassault ne peut pas les voir et je
suis avec mes copains syndicalisme et je
reconnais à la famille dassault d'être
des gens qui font ce qu'ils ont fait un
travail ils ont inventé des avions et
surtout ils ont inventé le plus grand
logiciels informatiques du monde qui
s'appelle katia il ya pas un train n'y a
pas un bateau il n'y a pas un avion dans
le monde qui se pressent ce logiciel
c'est un logiciel français
il ya des milliers de jeunes gens dans
les écoles qui sont prêts à servir la
patrie et vous prenez les jeunes gens
qui sont dans l'aéronautique qui sont
ingénieurs de l'aéronautique ou telle
plante est aujourd'hui quand ils sont
250 ils font un texte pour dire on va
faire des années autres mouvances
inventé d'autant de confiance en moi je
serai le pays a pas besoin d'alléger
parasites